democratic vice prez M&E senator Tim
Kaine is with us from Charlotte North
Carolina senator good morning good
morning guys what is your response to
the notion by Donald Trump that he may
not respect the election results and if
he does not what happens well Charlie
that was the big shocker of the evening
there were others but you know I lived
in Honduras as a missionary 35 years ago
and it was a military dictatorship and I
certainly learned there that one of the
central pillars of our democracy is
people accepting the outcome of
elections and the peaceful transfer of
power and that Donald Trump would try to
pull that pillar down after a campaign
where he has insulted everybody else and
now he's going to insult a very central
premise of our democracy was a huge
shocker I don't exactly know what it
means but it definitely means this
everybody should turn out and vote early
voting starts in North Carolina today
let's send the the biggest mandate we
can so that his wines after the election
do not attract any followers no senator
I ask this last night in post debate
coverage why do you think he'd said that
I don't have any idea although I think
Hillary may have gotten at something
which is he doesn't take responsibility
for stuff and so if something doesn't go
his way he's not going to say I guess I
should have ran a better campaign I
guess I shouldn't have been so divisive
he's going to blame it on somebody else
and Hillary used the example of him not
winning the Emmy and he couldn't resist
jumping back in and said I should have
won the Emmy that year he just doesn't
know how to take responsibility but that
is a trait that is required frankly to
be a good president respectfully senator
I mean this made it all the way to the
Supreme Court back in two thousand when
Al Gore contested the election results
so does he not have a point in some way
to say let's see what happens and then
I'll make a judgment if all he had said
during the entire last few weeks is of
course we're going to see what happens
on Election Day this wouldn't be a
controversy but he's going around again
and again perpetrating a lie that the
election is rigged he's saying that over
and over and over again because he knows
that he's losing and it's insulting to
voters
look him in the face and say you guys
don't know how to conduct an election so
look at county and state election
officials you don't know how to conduct
an election we do know how to conduct
elections we do it and that's why the
his comment last night was was so
shocking senator thirty-eight percent of
those we polled in battle ground States
say that Clinton they don't necessarily
believe tells the truth you've 19 days
left to convince them otherwise how do
you do that I think what we do is we
almost use that closing argument that
Hillary made last night when Chris kind
of gave him a chance to sum up and
Hillary just pointed out that she has a
lifetime track record of serving other
people with a special focus on families
and kids and and what I say about this
question on the trail is the best way to
tell somebody's character in politics is
look and see if they have a passion that
showed up in their life before they ran
for office and whether they've held on
to that passion throughout their life
Hillary Clinton has a passion she's
going to wake up every day focusing on
how her families and children doing as a
barometer for how is the larger society
doing Donald Trump has a passion but the
passion is himself it's not the serve
other passion that Hillary Clinton put
on display last night and that she's
demonstrated throughout her career
senator thank you